so I recently posted a picture of Jeff
Bezos on my Instagram account
highlighting the fact that Amazon has
increased value in the last hundred and
sixty five days by four hundred billion
dollars and the floodgates opened up
with comments and everybody started
saying this man Jeff Bezos who's worth
150 160 billion dollars doesn't pay his
five hundred and sixty three thousand
employees well they're on welfare
similar to what happened with Walmart
but the comments that I keep hearing
over and over again that is an absolute
cop-out from people is the following you
need money to make money it takes money
to make money all of these people that
like to hide behind the idea of that
rich people started off with money
here's a fact for you only fifteen
percent of millionaires in America
inherited their millions of dollars
eighty five percent ourself may matter
of fact having money is one of seven
ways of having equity today I'm going to
share with you the other six so look
when we hear the word equity we think
about real estate I have equity in a
home equity in the property of equity in
stocks of equity in bonds have equity in
cash that's equity right we only think
about equity as money if the only source
of equity you have is money you are
one-dimensional let me put it to you
this way if you the only thing you have
is money because somebody died and your
family left you 17 million dollars and
that's the only thing you have and mario
has the other six elements of equity
long term in the marketplace there is no
way in the world you have the same
amount of value as Mario's on a
marketplace so having said that your
goal watching this is as I go through
the other six is to ask yourself which
one of these do I have because if you
want to make yourself irreplaceable if
you want to make yourself the highest
value in a marketplace your goal is to
be able to have as many of these seven
as possible not just one of the seven
which is money but also the other six so
having said that let me get into the
other six elements of equity number two
so I want you to think about a son a
daughter just inherited seventeen
million dollars but this kid has been
spoiled 22 years old never had a job
before lazy as hell dad died mom died
they get them
right they have no clue how to work you
know how quickly that money is gonna
disappear out of their hands let me give
you another example of this how many
times have you seen somebody won the
lotto fifty eight million dollar winner
two hundred twenty million dollar winner
three years later money disappears
because they don't have the second part
which is sweat equity here's what
happens when you have sweat equity when
you have sweat equity you're not afraid
of working 16-hour days for six months
straight you have a certain mindset a
certain thickness your skin is thick you
have a certainly dark fighter you can't
explain to other people I can't give a
sixteen-year-old kid a million dollars
say go to school to get sweat equity
you're not gonna get it I can give a
twenty eight-year-old after they got a
degree let's just say they're very small
but they've never had a job saying I'm
gonna put a half a million dollars into
you to go to this program to learn more
real hard works all about you either
have sweat equity or you don't by the
way one of the seven forms of equity is
what equity this is why sometimes a
person would sweat equity who's hungry
wanted to go to the top like this
they passed up a multi-millionaire who's
absolutely lazy number three so let me
explain you the next one here and wait
that probably won't make sense to you go
back to high school okay think about the
kid whose parents were very wealthy and
he would come to school on a 5 Series
BMW right it's kind of gone my gosh this
kid man he's he's a nerd not really cool
nobody knows who he is but he's got the
5 Series BMW always had to mj's you know
the J's on $175 you're kind of like
weren't you Shawn Kemp like me size 13
you really size 13 you know what I'm
talking about right but this kid who
comes from a wealthy family always
wanted to be part of the in-crowd that
twenty two friends who were tight
hanging out together on Fridays going
out you know with the girls and
everybody were like oh that's the cool
crowd they wanted this kid with the BMW
wealthy family wants to be in that group
but couldn't make it in that group
even with this BMW why that group has
social capital they have social and
morale equity there's a bond right let
me explain to you a little bit more say
I get a group of six people they've
known each other for eight years they're
fought their friends they have something
they want to build together but they
work very very good together I can't pay
six other brilliant minds ten million
bucks and say I want you to have the
same kind of morale as these other six
people have it's just money
not gonna buy that morale you either
have it or you don't have it - a lot of
investors who come in and they look at a
group they can't find this often they
can't find a group that run well
together when there is something like
this in the room that's called social
and moral equity let me tell you it's
one of the seven can't buy it you either
see it and you have it or you don't have
it number four here's another one for
you let's just have a business can us
okay and I want to go on invest in - I
don't know let's pick China
I want to go invest into a market and
Central America that I think is gonna
come up I want to go investment to South
Africa they're going through struggles
right now a recession but I think
they're gonna come back up I'm gonna go
buy some you know stress properties
right if I go by myself and I don't know
the culture of China of South Africa or
pick a place in Central America I don't
have that equity but if I take somebody
with me who speaks the language of
Mandarin who lived in China for 22 years
who went to school there knows
everything I need him more than he needs
me because without him I can't get into
that community because what his equity
is culture and community he speaks the
language he understands the culture I
don't I could have a hundred million
dollars I need him that's another form
of equity number five here's another one
for you say I got seventeen million
dollars I'm a rich guy I got money I got
a lot of money right but I don't know
the right people and I meet this cat
who's got all the right contacts in a
community I'm trying to get into a
Silicon Valley I'm not a Silicon Valley
guy I'm an Austen guy maybe I'm a
Silicon Valley guy I want to get into
Hollywood different communities right
and I meet somebody
his name is Sean Parker my name is Mark
Zuckerberg Sean Parker introduces me to
crowd that I'm not a part of that crowd
helps me build a multi hundred billion
dollar company and Sean Parker makes a
billion dollars a couple billion dollars
because what Sean Parker had was the
contact and the connections that I
didn't have I was a basic nerd in
Harvard who was brilliant
Sean Parker was a cool cat who at the
context and the connections that is a
complete different form of equity that's
why sometimes a Rolodex or the cell
phone contacts there's a lot of equity
in it even though it's not money number
six so I want you to think about a kid
graduates out of high school goes to
college and he decides to study this
exciting topic of bonds for 1516 years
can you imagine like you wake up today
saying I am so excited to study
everything about bonds or stock market
or all these data man this excites me
right whoo and the right man wants to do
that well somebody does you know what
you call that specialized skill that is
a form of equity because a specialized
skill needs a person with money the
person with money needs a person with
specialized skill let me explain a
little bit more for you the movie Big
Short it's a story of Michael burry
right aka Christian Bale plays the role
this is the guy that when he was a kid a
football player tackled him his eyeball
fell out and he becomes fascinated with
numbers and he studies numbers and he
notices that sums happened with the
subprime market there's gonna be a
collapse here and he tells his investors
this is a nerd he studies numbers he
tells the investors two billion dollars
let's put into it was put in the market
let's buy everything short what are you
talking about yes the market are you
telling me the markets gonna collapse
yes I'm a nerd but I know it's gonna
collapse
we're gonna go to billion and he goes to
billion in everybody thinks he's nuts
specialized skill multi-billionaire you
know what happens billions are made this
specialized skill guy that was obsessed
about studying numbers for years now has
a net worth of 300 million dollars how
did it happen
specialized skill another form of equity
and number seven let's say your name is
angry charlie yeah
or Henry Sharia right and you for the
longest time we're living in Germany and
all of a sudden you get arrested right
and you go to prison called The Devil's
Island and anybody goes to Devil's
Island you psychologically lose it they
give you all this medicine you go crazy
and you somehow someway find a way to
escape Devil's Island and you make it
back to the country and you have all
this intellectual property things you
save your name is Patti on the writings
the articles paintings all of these
things you collected to getting you say
I want to tell this story to the world
and you go to Hollywood you produce a
movie called Papillon and the reason why
you have equity is because you have
intellectual property
that's another form of equity by the way
when I'm talking intellectual property
I'm talking about you can own domains or
a hundred different domains and you have
a domain that somebody needs to buy one
day
that's intellectual property you have a
script that you've written took you ten
years to write intellectual property
have a patent you have a trademark
intellectual property have an idea
intellectual property that meets with a
person with money in other context and
we go out there and produce this product
and we make millions together so look
now that you know there's seven
different forms of equity you got to ask
yourself which of the seven do you have
yourself or is it two of them is that
one of them is that six are you seven is
that four what other ways can you
increase your forms of equity to
increase your value in the marketplace
by the way Mario has produced a PDF for
you to download click on the link below
you'll be able to download the PDF and
ask yourself and score yourself on which
of the seven you have and for those
people who are watching this video in
the same pad it makes sense
maybe I am using money as a cop-out and
I'm trying to find a way to say this is
why I'm not rich this is why I'm not
wealthy if you agree with the concept
talked about in this video I want you to
go on Twitter and tweet the following if
you think it takes money to make money
you are simply looking for a cop-out and
tag me I want the world to understand
this message that there are different
forms of equity to attract money it's
not just money to make money again if
you haven't subscribed to the channel do
so if you want to be part of
notifications click on that alert button
right next to it
any other comments thoughts comment
below thanks for watching and love you
take care buh-bye hey look at me
if you are still saying it takes money
to make money and that's your way to cop
out knock it off
come on stop making excuses get out
there and find one of these other six
equities to have so you go out there and
attract the people with money